welcome back to las vegas now these days
especially you have to be aware of
renters scams i joined las vegas now las
vegas real estate now with harvey
blankfeld to learn more check it out
[Music]
welcome to our show this is las vegas
real estate now where we bring you the
three e's
educate empower and engage we want to
help you make your real estate decisions
wise ones for you and your family
i'm your host harvey blankfeld of the
blankfell group and today we have a
special guest we have rocky theaters
here
she's from channel 8. welcome rocky
thank you harvey it's good to be back on
the podcast
glad to have you back hey listen i want
to talk about property management today
and renters and tenants
uh tenants and landlords because there's
issues out there right now
so my first question is you know how do
people avoid these renter scams
you know there's a there's a handful of
scams going on out there there's a lot
of people saying they own homes and
trying to rent them and when they don't
actually even own it so first thing is i
suggest hire a realtor to help you find
a rental
and the reason you do that is because
the realtor will help you vet the home
to make sure that the
owner is who they say they are the
second thing is don't count on all the
information you see in those online
portals
some portals you might be surprised to
find out that the information there's
not active because they're allowing
people to put information on
independent of real estate agents the
inventory for rentals is very tight
maybe even and it's tight for buyers too
but maybe tighter for renters
so it's tough out there and out here the
rent is going
up right it is it's going it's gone up
at an alarming rate over the last
several years and it continues to climb
and i think there's just such a demand
because our population is growing
so why would a landlord actually need a
property manager they can't do it all
by themselves right well first of all
you want somebody to properly vet the
tenant that's one reason you want to
have a property manager the second one
is is that we know
the local laws and customs we understand
them and we insulate the landlords from
the tenants
you know if you if you have to give the
tenant bad news you don't want to be the
one to do it let us let us be
you you need a middleman yes let us be
the insulator between you and your
tenant that way you're still the good
guy
now what are those tenant
responsibilities versus the landlord
responsibilities
yeah i just want the tenants to remember
the the term that that we use throughout
is normal wear and tear
when you're closing out a tendency and a
tenant's leaving and and they're going
to get their security deposit back
the things that should be deducted are
those things that are above and beyond
normal wear and tear so you know you put
a few holes in the walls and pictures
that's normal wear and tear
if the carpet got a little dirtier over
a period of time that's normal wear and
tear
say a carpet's been in a home for 10
years and the tenant just moved in three
years ago
and then when they leave the carpet's in
really bad shape you can't charge that
tenant for the entire replacement cost
of the carpet because it's already been
in there seven years prior
the other thing is is that when a
landlord wants to charge too much we
have to kind of step in and say listen
this is what's proper and appropriate
and you could end up in court over
something like that
and that's where we're seeing some of
the laws change more in favor of the
tenants these days any more advice you
want to give people out there just to
kind of
protect themselves from these issues
read your lease
what's it say in the lease who's
responsible for this or that
the other thing is is that when you move
in take pictures of everything
so that when you move out and the
landlord says gee you just ruined that
you say no no no when i moved in it was
like that
all right educate empower and engage how
can people get more information
hey listen to us every saturday on kdwn
101.5 fm 7 20 am
every saturday at 11 a.m
[Music]
give harvey a call at 702-203-1111
or visit lvrealestateradio.com we'll be
right back